tell me about Captain America I never  thought this is what heroes were like we  brought you together because we needed  heroes his team we assembled we can't  even avenge ourselves how's your love  life money doesn't make you a better  hero sure doesn't hurt you're nothing  without that hammer you don't think I  see things that man doesn't stand for  anything and people love it for it I  don't have a drinking problem where does  that leave us the only people you are  married to your job and your wife  everything to use a chance to be a hero  you never say thank you that's what the  money is for things aren't what they  used to be I'm unhappy everybody's  unhappy  yeah  on the die